I do want to ask you since you are an
expert in psychology about our president
he has this need to tweet often
psychologically what does that mean
where does that come from well you know
I can't diagnose Donald Trump I know me
and you know him I do I know him I've
had him on the show I know him
personally and you know when you grow up
you just don't react to everything and I
think he feels like he has to react to
everything I think if somebody drives by
in a car and yells hey idiot I think he
would feel like he had to chase him down
and say something back to him you don't
have to react to everything right but I
think I think sometimes he just feels
like he has to react to everything you
know we have parental controls on
computers we should have presidential
controls on computers where you know it
doesn't you know maybe that would be
better for God's sakes if I responded to
every hater that posted or sent me an
email on the message boards I would do
nothing but respond what's that what's
something a hater has said to you I get
a lot of shut up you bald-headed
hillbilly I get a lot of those sort of
things to my face you said it when I was
ringing the game
I like to invite you over and then say
that as you walk in the door but I think
my favorite was somebody posted I would
rather have dr. pepper operate on my
dick than dr. Phil come on that's funny
it's good stuff I'm looking for a writer
so I got a detective or her down
you